BRIAN DORSEY: Hello.
I'm Brian, and we're
here to talk about--
where should I run my stuff?
So like all good
questions in technology,
the answer is, it depends.
And that's the reason
there's this whole talk.
So we're going to talk
through what it depends on
and how to make these decisions.
And basically, I'm going to
go through each of these,
except Firebase, and
talk about what they are,
what their sweet spots are, and
what the trade-offs are, like
how you might make a
decision between them,
and then some more kind
of bonus stuff around
how they can work together.
So each of these
I think of as part
of an abstraction layered cake.
So at the top, things are more
abstract, and at the bottom,
they're more concrete.
So the bottom, we
have VMs, right?
At the top, Firebase is a tool
for people writing mobile apps
and web apps where they
don't want to think
about the back end at all.
So it's kind of all
handled for you.
Down one level is
Cloud Functions,
and it's a really
good fit for things
that are primarily event
driven, or perhaps kind of glue.
Next down, we have
App Engine, and it's
for thinking about an
entire web app altogether.
Next one down combines web apps
and events with containers.
So you can run anything
that runs in a container
and serve it up on
the web with no fuss.
Next level down is
Kubernetes Engine,
which is hosted
Kubernetes for running
whole clusters of
machines running
an application, or
multiple applications,
with lots of containers.
And then next level below
that is straight VMs--
virtual machines.
Run anything you want to
that runs on a computer.
And by the end of
this, I'm going
to basically try to convince
you that this is a comparatively
low risk decision.
Don't worry too much about the
right or wrong choices here,
but still give you good
info on where to start.
So let's go through this,
and we'll start kind of top
to bottom, and start
with Cloud Functions.
So Cloud Functions are a
function, right, in the cloud.
I guess the name makes sense.
And it's basically you
write the function that
takes some parameters in,
perhaps has some side effects,
and returns a value, and
we handle all the rest.
And you write that into one of
the few programming languages.
And these functions
are triggered
by an event happening
somewhere else in the system,
either coming in from the
web, or from our message
through Pub/Sub, or from
Cloud Storage, which
is our object store.
So something happens
in the world,
and then your
function gets called.
That's the high
level model there.
And all the rest of
the infrastructure
is managed for you.
You pay for what you use, and
it auto scales up and down.
So as a developer,
you're thinking
about what events
make up your system,
and what the definitions
of the functions are.
So this is a really good
fit for serverless, right?
It almost kind of fits the
definition of serverless.
It is a really good
choice when you've
got Pub/Sub or Cloud Storage as
a key part of your application.
Anytime you really
don't want to think
about the runtime environment
at all, just how the pieces
connect, it's a good fit.
Data transformation-- people
don't necessarily think of that
as a top level thing, but
you've got information coming
in on a regular basis and you
need to make it in a slightly
different format--
that sort of thing.
And my favorite is that
I just think about it
as kind of web glue.
So we've got all these
different APIs that
help you do lots
of different stuff,
and sometimes all
you need to make
a system is to connect
two or three of them
together in a particular
way, and boom--
you've got some real value.
So it's a good fit for
that sort of thing.
On the constraint
side, since you're
thinking about functions all
the time, It's only functions.
And when you start
having lots of them,
it can be a little bit
challenging to kind of keep
track of them, or debug--
that sort of thing.
All of the interaction
is via events,
so if you want to
start them yourself,
you have to come up with some
other way to kind of poke it.
And we support certain
specific language run times.
Pretty good variety, but if it
matches what you need, great.
If it doesn't, you may have
to look somewhere else.
OK.
Next level down is App Engine.
So App Engine is arguably--
it is the earliest
Cloud thing that Google
did as a developer
product before we even
had the name Google Cloud.
And its goal is to really
help developers just focus
on the code.
So you've got a full code
base, the handles mapping URLs
to different parts of the code.
There's a couple different
data stores that you
can use with it nicely.
And all the rest of
the infrastructure
is handled for you.
So you're thinking
about your whole app
and all the different
parts of the web--
URLs that have handlers.
Since it is a very
mature thing, it
has deep support for things like
versioning, traffic splitting,
a lot of granularity in
seeing what's going on
with it, that sort of thing.
And I think you could
arguably say it was serverless
before it was cool, before that
term was really in popular use.
As a developer, when
you're using App Engine,
you're really thinking
about the code base,
you know, all of the code
that makes up your app,
and the particular web
requests that come in,
and which parts of the code you
want them to hit, what handler,
and what you want to do about
that, as the primary things.
That's where you spend
almost all your time.
And then, additionally, this
kind of idea of, OK, here's
a new version of the code.
I'd like to test that out with
a small amount of the traffic,
or move forward or
roll back afterwards.
It's a really good fit for an
application that is HTTPS--
HTTP or HTTPS web driven app,
for things that are primarily
stateless or use one of
our managed databases,
and especially
for scaling really
quickly from perhaps very
low levels of traffic
to very high levels of traffic.
One of the sweet
spot use cases is
things like landing pages
for seasonal events or things
like that where it
doesn't get really used
for most of the year, and
then suddenly super busy.
On the constraint side, again,
we have certain language
runtimes that are fully
supported-- things like Java,
PHP, Python, Go, Node, and
you really are speaking web
requests--
like the request, response.
That's how you have
to talk to App Engine.
Next level down the
abstraction tree is Cloud Run,
and this is where serverless can
really connect with containers.
And so what's a container?
Why containers?
Could go into a lot of depth
here, but concretely, we're
talking docker containers.
And I think of them as really
solving the problem you have
where the software works one
way on your dev environment,
but doesn't work in production.
You know, like, well,
worked on my machine--
that sort of thing.
So basically, they wrap
up the program, all
of the files it needs to run--
maybe some data files and
some stuff-- into a zip
file that gets pushed
to a repository,
and then that gets pulled down.
And every single time
the program's run,
it sees the same initial state.
So it kind of
solves that problem.
Containers are lovely.
They let you run almost
any software in them.
And Cloud Run is a
way to take anything
that does run in a
container on Linux
and connect that to the web,
connect that to the internet.
And so basically, you
listen for HTTP traffic,
and Cloud Run handles
the rest of it.
It does SSL termination for you.
It does the actual
traffic routing
to the different processes.
So it might run one.
It might run 50 to handle the
amount of traffic you have.
And, in fact, fairly
uncommonly, it
can actually send multiple
requests to the same process.
So if you've got a process
written in Java, Go, what
have you, where it can handle
multiple concurrent requests
at the same time, you
can do that in Cloud Run.
And since you're billed on
while that process is actually
running, you can handle multiple
requests in the same process
and save money.
So that's really nice.
It scales up and
down very quickly,
and very granular
[? billing ?] on usage.
So when you're writing
something in Cloud Run,
you are thinking about
building out that whole image--
the software that runs
in it, which files
are there, that sort of
thing-- and then, also, it's
kind of to you to figure out how
you want to build that image.
So anything from doing it as
a one-off on your computer
or, more likely,
using a build system
of some kind that then pushes
the resulting docker image up
to a repository.
And then, when you
set up Cloud Run,
you basically say, pull
from this repository
and run the
processes from there.
And the contract
is pretty simple.
You look at an
environment variable
for what port to listen on,
and you start a web server
and do work.
And then, the other
kind of constraint
is that there's no
local persistent storage
for that process.
So this lets us scale up and
down, [INAUDIBLE] processes,
start processes,
different places,
and handle lots of
traffic for you.
So that contract's
not super onerous.
It's not a super big deal.
So that means you can run
nearly any software that
runs in a container, and run
that in this very scalable way.
So it gives you a
lot of flexibility.
It's a really good
fit for workloads
that are inherently
stateless, for things
that are kind of web,
HTTP request response,
and, in particular, where you
have specific dependencies,
needs, you need to run a
certain programming language.
If you want to run something
written in COBOL or Fortran
and put it on the
web on Google Cloud,
this is going to be a
really good place to start.
Or if you've got
really particular
module dependencies--
maybe you've
got a Python module that
needs a library written in C
and needs to work a certain way.
This is a good
place to run that.
On the constraint
side, you do have
to think about and use
containers, so it's up to you
to figure out how you
want to do that build.
And then, in addition
to what I just
talked about with the fully
managed portion of Cloud Run,
there's also the
same exact contract
can be supported on
top of Kubernetes.
So you can then--
anything you write
to run in Cloud Run
can run anywhere
Kubernetes runs,
so that can be on Google
Cloud or another Cloud
or on your own
computers-- wherever
you've got Kubernetes going.
So that's really powerful,
which brings us to Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes itself is
an open source project.
It's essentially a de facto
software for running containers
at this point.
I think of it as kind of--
when you're like,
hey, containers.
That runs on my machine thing.
That's a good idea.
Let's do a lot of it.
And you end up, pretty
quickly, with thousands
and tens of thousands
of containers,
and you want to figure
out how to manage them.
That's the problem
space that Kubernetes
was built to help you with.
So it helps with that.
It helps you insulate yourself
from different physical
environments of computers.
And then I think it really helps
with a mental model of thinking
about an application, instead
of how the computers talk
to each other.
And then, Kubernetes Engine is
the Google Cloud hosted version
of Kubernetes.
So we handle all
the machine updates.
We've made it really easy
to get the cluster set up
and get connectivity to it,
help you scale up and down,
things like that.
So when you're using
Kubernetes, you
are thinking about the
logical infrastructure.
And I like to think about this
as kind of like the whiteboard.
So when you and a
colleague get together
and you start drawing lines
and boxes on the board
to explain how things
work, Kubernetes actually
works pretty close
to that level.
So things that would
be a box and a line--
you're going to
make a configuration
file that represents that--
[INAUDIBLE] file
somewhere to do that.
And so you're really thinking
at that level of abstraction,
and it's really powerful.
So what are the programs?
How do they connect?
Where do they source data?
How do they find each other?
What are they allowed to
do-- things like that.
It's a particularly good fit
for anytime you have a complex
software setup-- micro
services, or just, like,
half a dozen pieces that are
trying to talk to each other--
and you need to run that
in multiple environments.
So if you need to
run it in a test
environment, a
[? fraught ?] environment,
and have it work the same
way, or in different legal
environments where you have--
your main instance of the
cluster maybe runs somewhere,
and then you need to run another
instance in another country
because they have specific rules
around that your company needs
to follow.
So you can write the code
and the management work,
and do it in the same way
in both those environments.
So that's really powerful.
And it grew up with containers.
It's all about helping
you run containers.
So if you and your
team is focused
on using containers and
getting the most out of them,
this is probably a
really good fit for that.
And related to that,
though, I think
it's all in on
containers, so it really
means you need
good communication
between the different
teams and the roles.
So your dev folks and
your operations folks
and your security folks all need
access to the same repository
so that when there is a
security patch that comes out,
they can patch the same
place that the development
work is happening so that
it gets out to production
the same way--
that sort of thing.
And that gets into the
constraints a little bit.
So you need to be
using containers.
It's up to you to
figure out how you're
going to coordinate
the builds of those,
and how your teams are
going to work together.
And then there can
be, occasionally, some
challenges around licensing
or certain architectures,
but around licensing, in
particular, because it's
a pool of machines.
Some licenses want to
be machine specific,
and so there's some
options for doing that,
but you have to do a little
bit more configuration.
All of that is true
of Kubernetes--
all of these things-- this
insulation and abstraction--
that sort of thing.
The other point I just wanted
to make is that, I think,
part of the reason anybody
cares about containers--
and Kubernetes, as a whole--
a big one that's not
talked about too much
is that it helps you save money.
You can run more software
on the same computer,
or virtual machine,
without it messing up
the other software
on the same computer
because the containers
insulate them from each other.
And that means you can
get higher utilization.
You get more work done for
the same amount of money.
So that's really valuable.
And then, Kubernetes
Engine itself
gets you all that and, with
more management of the cluster
itself, as one big advantage.
And the other is
sometimes it's not clear
whether Kubernetes is going
to be a good fit for you,
or you want to learn it,
or whether it's going
to work on a given project.
And a managed cluster is just
the easiest way to get started.
You can have a cluster
going in five minutes
and then play with Kubernetes.
Even if you don't actually
intend to run it there
long term, it's going be
way easier to get it started
and figure out whether it's
a good fit for your problem.
So I recommend that.
Next up is Compute Engine.
So these are virtual
machines, and I'm
going to come back
to this phrase,
but I like to think about it
as a slice of a data center.
So basically, it's a
computer, and you've
got a certain amount of memory,
disk, and network and CPU.
The thing that makes our
general purpose machines,
in particular, really
awesome is that you basically
have a separate dial as an
option on each of those things.
You can attach multiple disks,
or different sized disks,
to any of the size machines.
You can have machines that
have more memory or more CPU,
depending upon the
actual workload you have.
So basically, you
don't have to pay
for the part of the
computer you're not using.
And it makes it easier,
especially for beefier systems,
to make a machine that just
matches the kind of work
that machine is doing.
You get the most efficiency
and not anymore, I guess--
not wasting anything.
And then we do have a
few specialized machine
types that are extra
large in either memory,
in particular,
for running things
like SAP HANA in
memory databases,
or for doing really
compute-intensive workloads.
So take a look at those.
And then, as a whole,
all of these-- they
start very quickly.
And we have a lot of
different operating systems
that are part of Compute Engine
that we do redistributions
of that have a few
extra tools in them
to make it really easy to run.
So that's Debian, CentOS,
CoreOS, Ubuntu, Red Hat, SUSE,
and, of course, Windows
Server, different editions.
So take a look at those.
And if you need to, you can
also roll your own distribution,
or build a custom organization
specific version of one
of these and resave that.
And I want to talk
about Disk for a moment
because that's
where I think this--
we normally think of a VM
as a slice of one computer.
And our Disks, and
network in particular,
are really-- you're getting a
slice of the whole data center.
The default disks,
the persistent disks,
are network attached
storage, but they're
on really fast networks, and
the blocks are spread out
across thousands of machines.
So you get most of
what you would get out
of SAN for every disk.
So things like you can
take an image of the disk
while it's running.
Restore that onto another
computer to look at it.
You can make any
of the disks larger
while the computer's running.
You can have disks
that are replicated
and actually live in one region,
spread across multiple failure
zones.
Things like that
really help out a lot,
and can drop whole parts
of your architecture
out, make things easier
to run and operate.
And then, they're more
than just computers.
So there's this handy thing
you can do where if you just
want to run one VM--
or one container on a
VM, you can just do that,
and we'll handle starting the
OS up and running the container
and downloading it.
And you just don't
have to worry about it.
And that's super handy if you
need a really big container,
for example, or you
just don't want to mess
with the complexity of
running a larger system.
And then, on top of
all the VMs, there's
this API called Managed
Instance Groups,
and it lets you treat a whole
group of machines as one.
So you have a template
for the OS disk,
and there's a dial, basically,
for how many copies of that
you'd like to run at any time.
So you can say, OK, I
want more, or I want less,
and we'll start up the
VMs, handle the load
balancing, and all that sort
of stuff, and connect them all
and have that work.
And then, in addition,
you can set up
to be automatic, so that
it scales based on traffic,
or you can run different
versions of the app
and see how they're doing--
things like that.
And then, the load balancer
itself is actually also
a data center level construct.
So when you change the
config of the load balancer,
you're actually changing
the configuration
for the whole data center.
And the same load
balancers we use for Gmail
and for YouTube are
serving your traffic,
and so it's not going through
one particular box somewhere.
So it can scale up really fast--
not limit the traffic.
So when you're using VMs, you're
thinking about everything,
right?
You're thinking
about your software.
You're thinking about
the operating system,
the disks you're
making for that,
the configuration of the
machine, how much CPU,
RAM, and disk, the
networking, how
they talk to each other,
firewalls, load balancing, all
of it.
So it's a lot, but
at the same time,
it gives you the flexibility
to run pretty much anything
that already exists.
So if you have an
existing system,
it's probably going
to be where it fits.
Yeah.
On that note, it's
like lift and shift--
a system that's
already running--
this is probably
where you're going
to want to start running that.
That use case I
talked about for,
like, I just want to run a
container-- really handy.
Also, if you have very
particular licensing
requirements--
it's maybe bound to a
particular machine--
we can handle that
on Compute Engine.
Or if you need a particular
kernel, or kernel extension,
or even a very specific OS--
maybe even a custom OS--
all of that can be
done on Compute Engine.
And it is where, I think, most
people run intensive databases.
It's running on time
of Compute Engine,
including our managed Cloud SQL
instances are, in turn, running
on Compute Engine.
And you can speak any IP
protocol network service--
any TCP protocol-based
network service.
So it's a good fit for a
really wide variety of things.
On the constraints
side, most of it
is that you end up having
to think about more.
And you have to decide how
to handle software updates.
And adding a new computer
takes, like, 20, 30 seconds.
So there's a larger
chunk of time
before you can respond
to new traffic.
OK.
So did I answer this question
of where I talk about my code?
Basically, we went through this
whole abstraction [INAUDIBLE]..
Things are more abstract
up top, and then kind of
get more concrete as we go down.
And each of them
has a sweet spot.
So if in talking about
that you were like, oh hey,
this is the one for me, great.
Go start there.
Take a look at that.
Maybe look at the
ones next to it.
But got it.
Let's start there.
Do that.
But there's-- it
still depends, right?
And I want to talk
about a few other things
it might depend on.
So there's this
abstraction level.
There's technical
requirements of the software
you're building, and
then there's your team.
What are the humans?
What do they like doing?
What are they good at doing?
How do the different
teams get along?
There are some factors
there to think about.
So let's go into those.
So abstraction.
I think we kind of spent
the most time on this.
Basically, what are the things
your team likes thinking about?
What is the best fit for the
problem you're working on?
And that may drive you to pick
a particular one of these.
So think about that.
Additionally, there are
technical requirements
for the software, and
these, generally, pull you
down the abstraction hierarchy.
So if you, for example,
need to use a GPU right now,
that's going to pull you down
into the lower level items.
If you need a really
specific Linux kernel,
that's going to pull you
all the way down to VMs.
So look at what your
technical requirements are.
Make sure that they work on
the service you want to use.
And, occasionally, it may
pull you down a level.
Billing model I didn't
talk as much about,
but basically, the top half is
based on transactional usage.
A request comes in and it
costs a small amount of money
to serve that request.
You get that sort
of thing going on.
At the bottom, we have more of
a while it's on, it costs money.
So you're making a reservation,
and even if you don't use it,
it still costs money, so
it's really to your advantage
to use it all the way--
get high utilization.
So how the billing
works for your software,
and how your organization
thinks about billing,
that also may
affect the decision.
And then also the team.
If your group is
entirely made up
of developers who don't want
to think about computers at all
and want to focus on the
code they're writing,
you're more likely to be
higher up in the abstraction.
And if you have a kind of
a multi-team group that
has really particular opinions
about how things should
be configured and how
they should work together,
you're much more likely to
be lower in the abstraction
hierarchy here.
So take a look at
your team makeup
and also just what you're
good at, what you like doing.
That may influence
your decision as well.
And then also, just--
how long has this code existed?
I think, generally,
I recommend if you're
starting something new,
try to start high up
in the abstraction hierarchy.
It's going to save you time.
It tends to be relatively
easier to move down.
It's to your advantage
to start and stay
up as high as you can,
as long as you can,
whereas if you've
got existing code,
it's almost always going
to work on Compute Engine,
and if it's in
containers, it's probably
going to work on Kubernetes
or maybe even Cloud Run.
So likely you kind of
start towards the bottom
and work your way up over time.
So maybe you migrate
into the Cloud,
and then you move parts of
the system into other things
later--
things like that.
So think about those things.
And then, when it comes to,
did I make the right decision--
actually, realistically,
most systems
are made up of multiples
of these together.
So it's pretty common,
for example, to have a--
it's primarily a
Kubernetes based system,
but you've got a few existing
apps that run on their own VMs,
and you've got some glue
that runs in Cloud Functions,
for example.
Or you might have any different
set of combinations there.
So that happens.
It's common and normal.
So just pick the right thing
for each part of your system.
So that's a good option there.
And we have a couple tools
to make that easier to do.
And as you get
more moving parts,
they become more
and more useful.
So Pub/Sub is our durable
and high throughput message
queuing system.
So you can pass messages
around to different parts
of the system without
them necessarily being up,
or you know about them.
And Cloud Storage
is an object store.
It's a key value store that
lets you save information
so that some other part of
the system, or you later,
can pick it up again.
So for the stateless
parts of the systems,
if you're using
lots of serverless,
chances are you'll store things
longer term in Cloud Storage--
things like that.
Or you may decide to move up or
down these abstraction levels
as you learn more
about your application.
So you may start up
high and then later
be like, actually, this
is already in a container.
We're going to move
it down a level
so that we can get
access to something
a little more specific.
Or we're adding a piece
to the system that
has a new technical constraint,
and that might pull you down.
Or you might be
starting down low
and decide you want to get
some of the management benefits
to move you up a level.
So we try to make it relatively
easy to move up and down.
Once you're in
containers, it gets
relatively easy to do that.
It's almost always just
very straightforward
to go down a level.
Sometimes it takes
a little bit of work
to move up an abstraction
level, but that's definitely
an option.
And then we try to make
the behavior as similar
as possible between these
different environments.
So there's a
metadata server that
is available in each of
these that you can get things
like security tokens from.
You can log into Stackdriver
and do monitoring and learning
the same way, using
the same code,
whether it's running on
any of these environments.
So try to make it pretty
easy to get back and forth.
And that brings us back to
our high level thing here.
So these, I think, are,
again, the sweet spots.
Things overlap a bit, so you
have a choice between two
or three of these sometimes.
But I think these are like
what I'd like you to remember.
If you've got an app that
looks like it's just a web app,
think about starting
with App Engine.
If you've got an
existing system,
probably think about
starting with Compute Engine,
that sort of thing.
And if you'd like to
get some more info,
here's some links and URLs
to go read a bunch more.
There's some quick starts for
trying things out and the like.
And my Twitter handle
is briandorsey,
and feel free to
email me at Google.
Thank you very, very
much for your time.
Take care.